in his commencement address at columbia
law school secretary of state anthony
blinken told students to do what they
love for a living
like he did when he quit his big firm
job for a less lucrative role in the
state department
what blinken didn't tell them was that
he made plenty of money anyway
today he's worth an estimated 10 million
dollars thanks in large part to
investments in real estate
after working for close to 25 years in
government and rising to become deputy
secretary of state in the obama
administration
blinken left that role and made a
killing in the private sector
in september of 2017 blinken co-founded
a firm called west exec advisors which
helps clients like uber and fedex to
leverage connections and conduct
business strategy
the firm grew quickly ernie blinken
guaranteed payments and distributions of
1.2 million dollars between 2019 and
2020.
his financial disclosure report also
noted at least 1.5 million dollars of
equity investments which he sold back to
business partners in march
during this time he began advising a
silicon valley investment outfit named
social capital
the role gave him an interest in a
social capital partnership worth more
than two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
overseas the former deputy secretary of
state also advised an infrastructure
investment fund in paris
where he lived during grade school in
high school
from january 2019 to august 2020 he
earned 134 thousand dollars from that
group
closer to home blinken joined the penn
biden center for diplomacy and global
engagement making 80 000 in the first
six months of 2019 and another 144
thousand dollars helping biden on the
campaign trail
there were also media opportunities
he started as a global affairs analyst
at cnn in february 2017
and though it's not clear exactly how
much he made we do know he earned at
least 22 thousand dollars for about six
months of work in 2019.
his wife evan ryan also made some money
in media
in 2017 she started at axios media as
executive vice president
her financial disclosure details a 125
thousand dollar salary
369 000 of income from exercising axios
options
and an interest in the media company
worth more than five hundred thousand
dollars as part of biden's transition
team ryan also made an additional 96 000
and she now serves as deputy assistant
to the president
all this money helped the couple to buy
a 4.3 million home in the dc suburbs in
2018.
they also accumulated over 500 thousand
dollars worth of stock in companies like
apple facebook and alphabet
now back in government their earning
power may diminish
of course as employees of the biden
administration blinken and ryan will
still receive hefty federal pensions
those payouts are currently estimated to
be worth about five hundred thousand
dollars and one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars respectively and will
only get more valuable the longer they
serve